so first things first to get the page we
need the generic HTML so let's start
with that that will give us a nice shell
of the page then as we're getting that
generic HTML we can fire off requests
for unique HTML we can start to load the
page with that generic HTML and then
finally finish it up with some unique
HTML the point being here that you could
actually separate this generic from
unique HTML and you can start rendering
the page you know rendering favorite
cereal favorite pasta maybe putting up
some space for an image even before you
start getting the unique HTML for things
that are specific to me this is a really
useful technique for quickly rendering a
page when custom content is evolved
there's almost always going to be some
type of generic HTML that the browser is
going to need so if we return it as fast
as possible and render it as fast as
possible it'll make our appt feel really
really fast we can always fire off the
request for unique HTML down the road
and then just fill in that data once it
arrives you'll notice with your facebook
news feed when it first loads you'll see
some empty stories that's facebook
following the technique you see right
here and the same thing is true for
google searches when you search for
something you will see the header come
back before the search results start
filling in because this is a really
great trick for getting content on the
screen as fast as possible